now to a truly remarkable story from
brazil where doctors have carried out
ground-breaking surgery on conjoined
twins the three-year-old boys were born
joined at the head their brains were
fused now doctors turned to virtual
reality they recruited experts from
around the world to conduct the complex
operation and to give the boys a chance
at life apart take a look
arthur and bernardo
two brothers that could not be closer
but until now had never looked each
other in the face
before their life-changing surgery the
boys had spent most of their lives in
hospital
i was so desperate for so long
because i couldn't handle their
diagnosis
years of research and trialing
techniques led up to the surgery that
was ultimately made possible by virtual
reality
brain scans created a digital map of the
boy's shared cranium which allowed
surgeons to perform a transatlantic
virtual reality surgery executed in both
brazil and in the uk
it's been described as space age stuff
i talked to their mother
and i told her i believed we were
capable of separating the children
i learned the phrase when you have one
percent of possibility the other 99
needs to be pure faith
faith definitely played its part in the
operating room during a grueling 27
hours of surgery where almost a hundred
medical staff were involved
whether it was faith or unmatched skill
and technology that ultimately pulled
through
it was a moment of joy and relief when
the twins were successfully separated
arthur and bernardo will need at least
six months recovering in hospital and
they may still need some further
procedures
but the brothers are finally side by
side holding each other's hands and
recovering well